what makes one an exceptional presenter
is it flashy visuals is it the tone of
voice is it the actual message or
content or does it have something to do
with body language or gestures and our
stance today we want to talk to you
about this latter point how do we use
our body effectively to communicate our
message because we have so many great
ideas here but if they remain in our
head don't actually link up with the
audience our message will not derive it
we are read message will not have
resonated with the audience so body
language plays a powerful role and how
we communicate and unfortunately body
language can also distract we've seen
this clip before of Michael Bay right he
speaks the teleprompter he loses sight
of what's happening the teller doesn't
sync up and he struggles and all you see
is his body moving around and he's
nervous he's exerting it so I want to
give some color commentary as we watch
as a class what is happening so he
stands at the beginning it's okay but
his hands is meshing them and now I'm
starting to turn from the audience
again his hands are clasped he's looking
at it down not at all of you the
audience and he spins he shows his back
audience and he can't be gained
composure he's swaying back and forth
he's looking down he's avoiding the
audience his nerves are coming out again
his hands
it's Maggie and now I think you looking
at the back of the stage that's the
exact opposite place and where you want
to actually look he's incredibly nervous
and now we exit stage we all want to
avoid our own Michael Bay moments run we
communicate the last thing we want at a
startup pitch or meeting is to have that
happen is to have the body language take
over from the message if we lose sight
of what our body is doing all people can
pay attention to is the body itself
right it'll take over so that comes down
to not only kind of distract but the
body language can it is your superhero
right that it can change
it's your superpower sorry not a super
here you're the super here but it's your
superpower in the sense that we can
utilize it to enhance and communicate
with every person in the audience we
want to talk about that today from three
vantage points Colin is going to get us
started and talking about how posture
breeds success Jung Joon is I'm going to
talk about gestures to strengthen your
message finally Jennifer is going to
close us out with how we think about the
body posture of you the audience and how
to interact with that Colin take us away
communication begins before you even
open your mouth to speak your audiences
first impression of you is your posture
in your position and so it's important
to know both how to stand as well as
where to stand and perhaps it's fairly
obvious but you should stand facing the
people you're talking to don't stand
facing your visuals and turning your
back to the audience that's not what we
want to do we can't communicate that way
it's also important to know where you're
standing in the room a position of
strength in this room is somewhere in
this center box as long as you're moving
around in the center you're doing pretty
well where you don't want to be is often
the corner cowering or especially in
front of any distractions and this this
room is pretty good it doesn't have that
many distractions but there is a window
and outside this window there
Barr's there are pluses there are bikers
and when I was standing over there
probably about half of you could see in
your peripheral vision outside the
window and if a car were to drive by
your instinct your reaction would be to
look out the window and that would break
your concentration and our conversation
and we don't want that either and now
that you know where to stand it's
important to know how to stand so we're
going to demonstrate a few positions a
few bad positions that we've seen from
us and some of you guys and even from
the presentations earlier today that you
shouldn't do the first one is hands in
your pockets this comes off as
nonchalant your shoulders tend to roll
forwards and it's very difficult to
convey a strong message from this
position second one is hands on your
hips when your hands are on your hips
you tend to look overbearing and
powerful and the third one is the
fig-leaf
this is where you're protecting your
family jewels with your hands and while
it also looks timid it's especially bad
when you decide to gesture from this
position I want to show you something
you look like you're flashing the
audience and that's not a good thing so
how should you stand and if I could
actually get all of you to stand I'll
lead you through a short demonstration
on how to find your face posture
so once you've stood be mindful of the
people next to you and place your feet
hip-width apart
close your eyes and look up towards the
ceiling and lift your hands above your
head
get a good stretch underneath your
shoulders and let your arms drop to the
side when you open your eyes look down
this is your base posture thank you very
much for participating you guys can sit
down now now that you've found your base
posture this is where you should gesture
from and it's where you should return to
when you're finished gesturing it may
not feel the most comfortable but it
looks the most comfortable to your
audience remember that your posture and
position are the audience's first
impression but now that you know how to
stand still it's time to learn how to
move just just sign Fulton's because it
helps you communicate for example if you
use gestures the audience remembers
twice as much it also helps you the
future speakers too because it helps
your memory when you speak also beside
the transition your hand and arm
movement is the biggest movement that
the audience can see you can either use
it wisely waste it random and
distracting gestures I'm going to show
you three types of gestures the give the
show and the chop it's an example this
photo at the GSP I went to this
communications class it was so brave I
mean you could feel that your skills
improve I think this was the best class
I've ever taken let's rewind and see
what happened the give this for at the
GSP I went to this communication
so this gesture is used to give the
audience the facts or the options
remember to have your palms up not down
we'll get to that in a minute the show I
mean you could feel better skills I'm
proving this kind of gesture has the
largest variety and your imagination is
the limit just remember that the gesture
and the message has to match for example
you can say profits are rising with a
gesture like so congruence and
creativity the chop I think this was the
best class I've ever taken
so this gesture is used to deliver
strong opinion you can either use it one
hand or you can use both hands you can
use both hands and do a larger chop
which will deliver us from the message
so next time when you do gestures think
about these three types and vanillin
three types is the give the show and the
chop I bet everyone in the room is going
to remember this just just work that's
the message
another subject is about having your
palms up so I'll give you an example
people have the right please rise and
move to the left as we slide the
different lists people on the left right
please rise and move to the left one
more time people on the right please
rise and move to the left you see the
difference which one do you think would
make more people move the first one yes
according to study if you have your
palms up 84 percent of the audience
complies if you have a thumbs down 52
percent if you have your fingers 28
percent never use your fingers that your
audience
it looks just arrogant and only
politicians use them clinton usually i
did not have sexual relations it looks
bad back then looks bad now and last but
not least avoid the tears gestures for
example people on the right please rise
and lose them no matter what you do
right i mean it looks silly so there's a
lot everybody
always remember that gestures are there
for you and the audience to make a
deeper connection so far we've talked
about the audience now it's time to
focus on you the audience as Jeong Joon
and Colin and Matt described we've been
focusing on body language of the speaker
but let's not forget who's the real hero
here as we learned in our first week of
class it's not me the speaker it's you
the audience but what happens when the
audience doesn't realize that they are
on this hero's journey have you ever
seen an audience that looks like this
have you ever been that audience it's
okay we all have whether we're playing
on our phones falling asleep and nodding
off looking at the clock and calculating
can we make an escape from this room
we've all done it but the thing is it's
the speaker's responsibility to
understand what's going on with their
audience and body language is a powerful
way to assess that as a speaker we can
be so focused on our own body language
that we never even notice what the
audience is doing and it's important to
change that so I want to share three
strategies for how you can engage with
your audience better by developing more
observational skills so first of all
absolutely be using the gestures and
body language tools that we've talked
about today and
over the course of the quarter but the
second thing is to notice of course
you're going to be looking for eye
contact but look beyond it look at how
you're about how your audience members
are sitting are they fidgeting are they
moving are they leaning forward looking
engaged and taking notes or are they
zoning out if your body language your
eye contact and your efforts at being
compelling or not working then you can
go deeper you can try to surprise the
audience with a question or use some
humor or you can disrupt the audience as
students we hate being cold called but
we know it's effective right Jason
what's your favorite color okay very
good
you got that one as we all know it's the
fastest way to re-engage with the
conversation with the speaker so don't
be afraid to use it it's so important to
keep your audience on track because
they're the hero and it's their journey
remember how Nancy Duarte told us that
we are the Yoda to the Luke Skywalker
and our job as the speaker is to keep
the hero on their journey with that in
mind I think we've talked about three
concepts that really remind each of us
about how body language is your
superpower use it become that superpower
sound that superhero and we welcome any
questions you have on how to stand
strong gesture effectively and engage
the audience thank you
you